dans 20 ans les agriculteurs français
auront disparu j'ai écrit ça il y a 3
ans et on continue à descendre donc 20
ans j'étais peut-être optimiste
attention he les agriculteurs qui qui
qui quittent un village qui quittent une
région un département c'est les
commerces qui plongent les artisans qui
qui plonge c'est toute une induction
économique et sociale qui disparaît la
popérisation des territoires elle est
systématiquement du à la déprise
agricole en France en Allemagne aux
Pays-Bas mais aussi en Pologne le monde
agricole est en ébul y y a-t-il selon
vous une convergence entre ces
mobilisations c'est une convergence
parce qu'il y a effectivement ce
problème de charge qui est commun à
l'ensemble des producteurs européens
l'agriculteur en général ne peut plus
supporter ces hausses de charges à
répétition tout le monde à un moment
donné se plain de de la hausse des des
intrans bon engrais et cetera des
produits de phyo de la hausse de Ben des
carburants de l'énergie de de de tout
matériel tout augmente il y a eu
évidemment l'inflation tout le monde l'a
subi quoi voilà avec des des des normes
de plus en plus draconien je crois
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut vraiment
arriver à réorienter l'agriculture il
faut lui donner les moyens d'être
compétitif face aux produits importés et
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
domaines quoi c'est la même chose dans
l'industrie dans le textile on a vu la
sidirurgie on a vu partout aujourd'hui
l'agriculture certains parlent d'un plan
social qu'on est en train de c'est un
peu ça en fait c'est un peu ça he on
passe de 100 millions d'individus à
400000 en un demi-siècle dans 20 ans les
agriculteurs français auront disparu
j'ai écrit ça il y a 3 ans et on
continue à descendre donc 20 ans j'étais
peut-être optimiste attention hein les
agriculteurs qui qui qui quittent un
village qui quittent une région un
département c'est les commerces qui
plongent les artisans qui qui plongent
c'est toute une induction économique et
sociale qui disparaît la paupérisation
des territoires elle est
systématiquement du à la déprise
agricole pour répondre à la mobilisation
en France le gouvernement prépare une
grande loi d'orientation agricole quelle
devrait être selon vous ses priorités
premier point absolument diminuer les
charges voire les bloquer deuxième point
en France on est les meilleurs élèves de
la Communauté européenne et même du
monde peut-être pour les normes les
contraintes
administratives environnementales tout
ça c'est pareil il faut lever le pied
là-dessus c'est-à-dire l'agriculteur il
faut le laisser travailler aujourd'hui
il il a pas sorti le tracteur de de du
hangar que déjà il doit montrer pattes
blanche toutes les 5 minutes ça c'est
plus possible et ensuite c'est plus
sociétal comme question il faut qu'il y
ait une prise de conscience et je pense
que le gouvernement a un rôle à jouer
là-dessus certains médias ils ont une
propension à stigmatiser le monde
agricole actuellement il faut que ça
s'arrête ça ça suffit le glyphosate il
vous montre un tracteur en train de
soi-disant désherb sur des arbres on
dsherbe pas sur des arbres c'est faux
sinon on détruit les récoltes ces
imagesl elles sont elles sont ancrées et
une fois que c'est parti c'est parti
c'est irréversible ces trois choses là
ça ça pourrait faire l'objet dans une
loi d'orientation d'une réflexion serrée
et rapide revenons d'abord au premier
point sur lequel vous insistez celui sur
les charges selon vous l'agriculture
française a d'abord besoin d'une forme
de protectionnisme le protectionisme
c'est un gros mot mais bon quand on sait
que par exemple la
tomate qui est produite au Sahara
Occidental colonie du royaume chérifien
5 6 7 € par jour les gars ils sont
embauchés dans ces fourchettes là ça
arrive sur le sol français et puis bon
pouvoir d'achat oblige bon ben les gens
achètent parce que c'est comme ça hein
c'est comme ça c'est inacceptable
totalement inacceptable parce qu'en plus
bon c'est c'est produit dans des
conditions sociales déplorables
environnementales certainement en plus
il y a le transport on casse le marché
on usurpe nos marchés traditionnels tout
ça il faut qu'à un moment donné bon ben
on s'en protège de ça d'où le fameux
protectionnisme ces tomates là
elles ne doivent plus arriver sur le sol
français dans la mesure où il y a une
distorsion qui est inacceptable c'est de
la géopolitique c'est de la géopolitique
ça voilà moi je me rappellerai toujours
on avait été reçu à l'époque par shirac
à l'Élysée petit groupe le cnjia parle
il y a quelques années j'avais évoqué la
question des des des tomates des tomates
il y avait une mévente en tomates dans
le dans le sud et bon alors il m'avait
dit connaisseur quand même connaisseur
du du monde agricole il m'avait dit
combien combien de tonnes là 4000 tonnes
jour ça devait être à peu près ce qui se
faisait sur le bassin et puis le
problème il vient d'où ben l'Espagne et
le Maroc quoi il me dit vous savez il
m'avait répondu comme ça la paix en
Méditerranée personne ne s'y opposera il
avait tout dit on est dans la
géopolitique au même moment je pense que
la France Aznar avait laissé déployer
quelques portavion là-bas au large de
Gibraltar c'est tout bon mais est-ce que
l'agriculture doit continuer à faire les
frais de tout ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
les eaux virtuelle de la Méditerranée on
a toujours envoyé des céréales du moins
jusqu'au printemps arabe a ça s un peu
gâté on a vu que ça marchait pas trop on
a envoyé des céréales vers les pays du
Maghreb procheorien MoyenOrient très
bien il n'avait pas de quoi les irriguer
les produire c'est pour ça qu'on a
appelé ça les eaux virtuelles de la
Méditerranée et en échange on a laissé
rentrer avec des tas d'accords
bilatéraux on a laissé rentrer des
fruits et des légumes là par contre on
fait la FNS fait moins la fine bouche là
à ce niveau hein en plus on fixe les
populations là-bas même même à 5 € par
jour on les fixe nous qu's envoient des
céréales bah bah c'est bien tant mieux
pour eux problème c'est que quelque part
on aurait bien aimé qu' qu' mettent
autant
d'énergie à défendre pendant 30 ans les
producteurs de fruits et légumes
français en
dénonçant et et non en cautionnant les
accords bilatéraux avec les pays du
Maghreb que que l'énergie qui déploie
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il déploie il se
réveille il se disent ou là attention on
va avoir des accords bilatéraux qui vont
nous ruiner le Mercosur le ah oui mais
bon ben nous on peut leur expliquer
comment ça s'est passé on l'a vécu et il
faut être fait d'un bois
particulièrement dur pour résister à ses
importations sans soutien en plus
c'est-à-dire ça sans amortisseur
économique et bon la plupart
malheureusement en fruits et légumes
surtout sur le pourtour méditerranéen
bon parfois on plié boutique il en reste
encore qui on qui ont passé le cap
difficilement mais qui ont passé le cap
mais bon euh c'est ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que la la FNSEA
les syndicats quel qu'il soit considère
de la même manière celui qui produit des
fruits et des légumes et qui le
défendent de la même manière que celui
qui produit des céréales voilà qui en
plus bénéficie des aides pack alors que
le premier en bénéficie pas sauf quand
il doit investir mais pour investir il
faut avoir un marché porteur voilà ce
qui n'est pas le cas vous parlez des
aides de la PAC qui sont un élément
centrale de la politique agricole
européenne pouvez-vous nous rappeler
comment fonctionnent ces aides alors la
pâack d'All lesganes de longueur il y a
des aides directes qui sont attribué
pour les secteurs qui qui en bénéficient
principalement grande culture et élevage
les aides européennes don la PAC sont
indispensables pour certains c'est 80 %
du revenu s'il n'y avait plus ces aidesl
ce serait un champ de jeuner et de ronce
de la frontière espagnole à lillele à
l'origine on a voulu aider ces secteurs
là parce que on était dans une phase
c'était la prèsgerre après traité de
Rome il fallait absolument produire
relancer la machine alimentaire c'était
nécessaire indispensable à côté de ça il
y avait des secteurs fruits légumes vin
qui ne sont pas rentrés volontairement
dans ce système-là parce qu'ils n'ont
pas voulu être soumis à des prix à des
quotas ils ont dit nous tout va très
bien on c'était dans les années 60 on
veut pas on veut pas d'aide parce qu'on
ne veut pas qu'on nous impose un prix et
cetera ce qu'il n'avait pas vu venir
c'était justement l'arrivée des pays
émergents concurrents qui eux allent
laminer totalement certaines productions
agricoles donc aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on a on a des des des secteurs qui
sont aidés directement à la production
et puis il y a des secteurs qui sont
aidés je pense notamment fruits et
légumes sur l'investissement le ciste m
il veut monter un hectare de serre il
dépose son dossier le pouvoir public lui
lui l'aide à hauteur de 25 30 % là j'ai
plus j'ai plus les chiffres en tête et
le reste ben il faut qu'il aille la
banque et qu'il emprunte voilà la
fameuse convergence des aides elle est
soit-disant appliquée depuis quelques
années c'est 40 € par-ci 40 € par là
c'est pinuts ça ça se connaît pas mais
peut-être justement quand la céréale se
vend bon et
bien ajuster les soutiens européens et
peut-être qu'il y ait une convergence
sur redistribution vers les secteurs qui
sont
euh un peu moins à l'aise sur les marché
voilà pourquoi pas si on va en sortir
dans une communauté agricole unie je
crois que ça fait peut-être partie des
choses qu'il faut examiner n'est-ce pas
déjà une forme d'échec que de considérer
que l'agriculture française est
condamnée à vivre sous perfusion pendant
quelques temps la perfusion est sera
nécessaire hein parce que si si on
arrête demain de soutenir les secteurs
qui le sont aujourd'hui même s'il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire là-dessus
c'est ce qu'on vient d'évoquer et qu'il
faut aller vers une convergence part
partage de ces aides je pense que ces
secteurs là je pense notamment à
l'élevage l'élevage qui ne pourra pas
s'en sortir il faut penser qu'il y a la
pression mondiale qui mettra le pied
dans la porte puis c'est fini on perdra
les marchés on perdra les marchés il
faut rester présent sur les marchés faut
surtout pas lâcher quoi si demain on
lâche des des des des parts de marché
sur tous les produits on on les
récupérera jamais on les récupérera
jamais ce sera irréversible quoi c'est
ce qu'on a vu la nergie le textile tous
ces secteurs on l' plus jamais récupéré
comment convaincre qu'il faut donner
plus de liberté aux agriculteurs quand
on sait que l'agriculture a pu avoir un
passif lourd sur l'environnement et que
l'urgence climatique est une
préoccupation croissante il faut déjà
aller sur le terrain sur le terrain et
regardez comment fonctionnent les
agriculteurs moi je vis dans le monde
rural depuis toujours j'ai vu cette
évolution il se fait plus n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui j'ai tendance à dire qu'il
se fait moins de conneries dans les
campagnes qu'en ville ça c'est quand
même important les agriculteurs savent
qu' ils font ils font attention en
permanence je crois que le discours
selon selon lequel l'agriculteur est
responsable de tout ne passe plus dans
les campagnes et ne tient plus comment
vous voulez expliquer à des jeunes qui
ont vu leurs parents s'endetter qui ont
vu leurs parents stigmatiser se faire
insulter quand ils sortent les pendeurs
la tonalisier le pulvérisateur les
jeunes ils abandonnent ils y vont pas il
faut être fou voilà il faut être fou on
est passé du stade où il fallait nourrir
les gens où l'agriculteur était respecté
parce qu'il nourrissait les gens il y
est parvenu il y parvient encore au
stade où ben c'est devenu le le type
qu'on accuse d'empoisonner de de de
polluer alors qu'il continue à nourrir
les gens quand même l'agriculture de nos
grands-parents après elle elle était
justifiée parce que on était dans cette
cette
dynamique le plan Marshal et et cetera
et cetera il fallait après après la
guerre reconstruire nourrir et cetera
aujourd'hui on en est plus là le monde
paysan est conscient d'abord le monde
paysan vit dans la nature tout ce qu'il
fait a un coûte donc quand il doit
traiter une production c'est vraiment
par nécessité ou alors il perd la
production et ça ça lui coûte de le
faire il est le premier exposé il y a
une prise de conscience enfin bon quand
même vous êtes très sévère envers les
environnementalistes comme vous les
appelez y a-t-il encore un dialogue
possible entre agriculteurs et militants
écologistes je pense que le dialogue il
peut être restauré s'il est pas
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui on
assiste quand même à une récupération
politique de
l'écologiein tout est bon tous les coups
sont permis et l'agriculteur c'est lui
qui ramasse toujours il est toujours
devant pour ramasser vous décrivez les
agriculteurs comme victimes d'une forte
défiance pourtant dans la crise qu'il
traverse il sembleent avoir l'oreille
des responsables politiques et un
soutien très majoritaire de la
population n'est-ce pas paradoxal quand
il y a eu le covid quand il y a eu le
covid tout d'un coup on a on a senti une
espèce d'engoument pour le monde
agricole et là on a été quelques uns
effectivement à se dire ah tiens c'est
pas mal ça et je pensais franchement
qu'ilit y avoir une espèce de prise de
conscience elle a été de courte durée
elle a été cour durée l'agriculteur
était devenu tout d'un coup le type
indispensable comme pendant la guerre
quand il y a rien à bouffer finalement
voilà et puis après bon on est passé à
autre chose et l'agriculteur et de
nouveau de nouveau il y a eu cette
espèce de de de stigmatisation
d'acharnement récurrent là comme ça sur
le sur le sur le monde agricole est-ce
qu'il faut vraiment qu'il y ait des
périodes difficiles de manque pour que
la la population prenne conscience de
l'importance du monde agricole c'est
quand même dommage ça c'est quand même
dommage parce qu'entre-temps entre-temps
ben l'agriculteur lui il est pas soutenu
quand il aura envoyé valcer par-dessus
les moulins son activité c'est là qu'on
dira tiens ils sont où les paysans ils
sont où ils sont passés voilà ce sera
trop tard le gars le gars qui quitte une
exploitation il revient pas et
l'exploitation souvent d'ailleurs elle
disparaît l'agriculture française
n'a-t-elle pas également des problèmes
structurels alors qu'on a l'impression
qu'elle va de crise en crise de manière
quasi incessante depuis des années faut
aller plus loin que ça s'il y a
aujourd'hui une des revendication
récurrente c'est qu'à un moment donné
les résultats n'ont pas été obtenus si
les résultats n'ont pas été obtenus
c'est que peut-être et là j'en parle
d'autant plus facilement que j'ai
appartenu à ces obédience syndicale que
ce soit FNSEA ou jeunes agriculteurs
j'ai été à l'occurrence avandonné
président des Jeunes Agriculteurs j'ai
siégé à Paris avec Christian Lambert à
l'époque il y a une espèce de faut oser
le terme de cogestion on peut
difficilement aujourd'hui
euh manger avec un ministre un président
un préfet le lundi et aller manifester
devant sa porte ou le le le lendemain
c'est pas possible ça donc il faut qu'il
y ait de la rigueur quand je faisis du
syndicalisme j'ai même fait un peu de
prison à un moment donné je pense qu'il
y a deux règles la première c'est on ne
s'excuse jamais la seconde de c'est on
ne dit jamais merci voilà et comme ça on
se fait respecter ça ça n'existe plus et
parce que ça n'existe plus ça ne marche
plus c'est-àdire qu'aujourd'hui euh il
faut que les les syndicats les
représentants de syndicats agricooles il
restent c'est le cas de le dire droit
dans leur botte et puis quand euh euh il
voit que ça marche pas avec avec les
représentants des pouvoirs publics mais
il faut pas lâcher il faut pas c'est
comme ça parce qu'ils ont un mandat ce
mandat ils doivent le porter pour faire
respecter la profession et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui pêche un
petit peu les gens n'y croient plus les
gens n'y croient plus d'une
manifestation à l'autre le problème
c'est le renouvel de l'exploit il faut
obtenir le résultat quand on dit aux
gens vous tracassez pas on va obtenir si
on obtient pas il faut y revenir il faut
du souffle et c'est peut-être ce que
sont parvenus à faire les alleban parce
que pour sortir autant de tracteurs dans
la rue il chapeau hein franchement
chapeau hein voilà alors bon peut-être
que en France ils y parviendront mais
j'en doute cette radicalité que vous
prenez n'est-ce pas celle que vous
reprochez au militants écologistes qui
s'oppose parfois violemment aux
exploitants agricoles vous savez quelle
est la différence entre l'activiste de
sainte Soline et le mariché que j'ai
aidé été qui qui en l'occurrence
contrôler on va dire ça comme ça les les
camions à la frontière et c'est tout
simplement que ces gens-là défendent des
idées moi je défendais mon métier c'est
tout voilà les idées je vais être très
terre à terre ça nourrit pas son homme
le métier ça le nourrit et quand vous
avez des prêts à rembourser à la fin de
l'année que vous voyez les marchandises
arrivriver que vos marchés sont sont
toujourspé par ces mêmes marchandises là
à un moment donné quand vous sentez que
vous allez pas pouvoir payer le
personnel pas pouvoir payer la MSA pas
pouvoir payer le marchand d'engrais pas
pouvoir rembourser vos dettes et nourrir
votre famille ben là vous pétez un plomb
et vous vous dites il faut faire quelque
chose c'est ce qui peut-être est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui à l'
Allemagne en France un peu partout
tandis que ces gens-là qui vont à sain
Soline qui vont chez le maréché nanté
ils arrivent ils rentrent là-dedans ils
pètent tout ils pètent tout pourquoi
parce que euh ils défendent soi-disant
des idées déjà ils vont tout péter chez
les autres voilà puis surtout qui
viennent pas dire qu'ils sont là pour
défendre l'agriculture comme je crois
Jad l'avait dit à un moment donné parce
que non non quand on défend
l'agriculture on commence par la
respectter on va pas tout casser chez
les paysans voilà ça déjà ça commence
par là il quelques uns ce sont des
enfants gâtés du système en plus très
bien bon ben
écoutez moi je pense que s'ils veulent
vraiment aujourd'hui je le dis ça je je
l'ai souvent dit s'ils veulent défendre
une agriculture française vertueuse qui
commence par aller contrôler tout ce qui
rentre par les frontières et comme ça
ils permettront à l'agriculture
française de se sécuriser et en même
temps ils y feront des découvertes très
intéressantes concernant ben ma fois la
façon dont ces productions sont
produites qu's allent voir le roi du
Maroc là-bas et que a manifesté devant
la porte du roi du Maroc certains
militent pour le retour d'une
agriculture paysane sur de plus petites
exploitations est débarrassé de
l'obsession des rendements pensez-vous
que cela puisse être une solution dans
le détail quoi ils vont nous envahir et
puis c'est tout c'est tout ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ils prendront les
marchés on en parlera plus quoi voilà
c'est fini c'est très dangereux c'est ce
genre de
choses quand je vois des écologistes
parler depuis les studios parisiens ils
ont traversé la rue là et puis ils se
mettent à parler comme ça de choses
qu'ils ne connaissent pas non non non il
faut aller dans les champs il faut y
vivre puis il faut pas il faut pas dire
moi je connais l'agriculture parce que
j'ai été en vacances chez le PP quand
j'étais petit et puis on va péter quatre
bassines à Sainte Soline on va saccager
la serre de maréchénanté on idéalise et
puis voilà mais ça me donne le droit à
devenir
agriculteur ça me donne le droit demain
à faire une autre forme d'Alien
d'agriculture bon beaucoup moins
productiviste et cetera et cetera non
non c'est pas du tout ça hein ces
gens-là sont totalement incapables de
nourrir l'humanité ils vont essayer de
le faire dans des proportions totalement
insuffisantes on peut pas demain prendre
un Lop pain de terre se mettre à
cultiver vous avez un insecte qui arrive
ah mais non mais euh on le tue pas il
faut pas sulfater bon mais c'est pas
compliqué de toute façon la culture elle
est foutue voilà très bien on peut pas
faire ça voilà c'est c'est pas
[Musique]
possible